[Music]
you know I want to talk about the iPhone
5 again it's been out for two weeks it's
been getting a lot of praise but also
it's getting some criticism particularly
about the Apple maps feature now I've
been thinking about getting the iPhone
but I want to know what to expect so I
asked one of the writers who has one to
give us his personal review he's gonna
do that now please welcome Deon Cole
idea out
thanks Conan I love my iPhone 5
finally a phone footed brothers see see
it has this great new feature that lets
you take panoramic pictures so now you
can fit something really long in one
frame done
I don't know what you're doing what are
you doing it's a sexual bravado Conan
it's our friend Chris Parnell Chris did
you say miss Bernette I'll see you Chris
Poorna did you say sexual bravado that's
right
it's a very simple Conan Dianna is using
the familiar racial stereotype of the
well-endowed black man to praise the
capabilities of the new panoramic camera
on the iPhone 5 Dion is implying that
his penis is too large to be contained
in the aspect ratio of a normal cameras
field of view a picture of a penis of
average length shot from 18 inches away
requires a focal length of 58
millimeters now the iPhones panoramic
option simulates a focal length of zero
point two millimeters without the barrel
distortion of a fisheye lens that means
Dion's camera could capture the image of
an object that is 48 meters long now how
long is 48 meters imagine NFL
quarterback Peyton Manning standing at
the base of Dion's shaft Manning would
have to fire a monster 52 yard pass to
reach the other end of Dion's penis
Dion was implying he has a 52-yard penis
is that what you meant Deon yes
[Applause]
or thanks to chris parnell thank you
Chris
[Applause]